What you're about to see is going to melt your brain.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie Marvel just announced Moon Knight Season 2
and a couple other shows will be getting season 2,
so we'll break it all down
It is finally time for Moon Knight to try and kill God.
weirdly, something that should have been happening
during Thor, Love and Thunder, since they use Gorr
the God butcher
But there wasn't a whole lot of God
butchering that happened during that movie.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Of course I'll be doing them for the series
when it does actually release.
but you may have seen some of the season
two talk in your feeds.
Recently. There were a number of different series
that they announced.
Moon Knight is just one of them,
all focused mostly on that during this video.
Just because we know more
about what's actually going on during that Oscar Isaac
even gave away the fact that they were planning season
two over a year ago in a video.
Thank you very much.
The question on everyone's mind is this season two,
of Moon Knight
Why else will we be in Cairo?
that seems pretty straightforward.
I'd say he was trying his hand at joining Team
Spoiler Bros,
but just revealing that they were working on a season
two isn't really a spoiler,
and it's still going to be a while
before they actually get around to start filming it.
there were a bunch of deleted storylines
and things that they could
not include in season
one that they can bring back for season two.
All explained those during the video because
some of them are pretty big, like Kit Harington's.
Black Knight was supposed to show up during season one.
Werewolf by Night is a big character
is part of New Knight's Origin story.
they couldn't include him during season one
because they were introducing him during the special
that same year in bast,
the Panther goddess who's the God of Black Panther,
and most of the people in Wakanda
They're a couple Easter eggs for her during season one.
But they couldn't really use her in a big way
because they were using her
during Thor Love and Thunder,
which was coming out around the same time.
she's from Khonshu's pantheon of gods.
She's Khonshu's sister.
there even a couple Easter eggs
for the Rama Tut version of Kang
because obviously this is all leading towards Avengers
five and Avengers six Secret wars.
so there were just a lot,
a lot of really big connections
to the wider Marvel universe
that they couldn't really include.
There's a lot of really cool parts of his backstory
too, that they can bring back for season two.
But the end of Moon Knight Season one set up
a lot of the events that season two will deal
with pretty well in that taxing.
At the end, it was revealed that Moon Knight
had more personalities inside him than he realized
during the season, they were only Khonshu's
of the original Mark Spector personality in the Steven
Grant persona during the taxing, presumably after he'd
fallen asleep At some point at the end of the season,
the Jake Lockley persona became dominant, which
we'd had some Easter eggs for earlier in the season.
Like, Wait a minute, who killed all these people? Like,
what happened here?
Why is there a massacre here?
because it was Jake Lockley.
there, a couple of
moments where they were both pointing at each other,
saying, was it you that killed all these people?
Now, was it you that killed all these people? Well,
it wasn't me.
It wasn't me.
Then who was it?
So at some point,
the end of the season, they fall asleep.
The Jake Lockley persona becomes dominant,
and then Kaiju forms a new contract with him
to become his avatar, reasserting his control
over their collective body, so to speak.
Because even if he only has a contract
with one of the personalities,
he still gains control over their entire body.
it if he were sure during season one
I think they were pretty clear about implying
what was really going on
Khonshu was meant to be the real villain of season
one and will continue
to be the real main villain of season two?
They really wanted to end season one,
letting you know how terrible he was.
Like he was never going to let Moon Knight,
Marc Spector.
The other personalities go,
they would always be under his control.
So he has Jake Lockley kill Arthur
hero in the backseat of that limo on
his orders in that moment is meant to be
from the comics with him in the business suit
so the whole idea during season two is that Marc
Spector, Steven Grant become aware of Jake Lockley
as existence in the three of them battling it out
for control of their body first, while they're
still under Khonshu's control, he can still force them
to do whatever he wants them to do.
can't.
You also implied in that tag scene
that there were many more personalities inside his body
that he could form subsequent contracts with,
and he could continue to break his mind
so that he would develop even more personalities
beyond that, That was the whole idea
is that Marc Spector developed all these alternate
personas to deal with all this childhood trauma
just because there were a couple
that we knew about in his body
didn't mean that more couldn't surface through time.
all Kaiju has to do is just push him harder and harder
and harder until his mind breaks even more.
giving Kaiju
more and more personalities to form a contract with
the other personalities that we know about from
the comics are the Mr.
Knight persona who's like a world's greatest
detective Batman kind of persona.
There's a lot of Batman references that people make
when they talk about Moon Knight,
but when people call him Marvel's version of Batman,
that's mostly just a joke.
He's very different from actual Batman.
But Mr.
Knight is a relatively recent comic book creation,
In the comics, there's also a fifth personality
because they treat the Moon Knight persona
as being totally different
from the original Mark Spector persona On the TV show.
They made it seem like that was still just regular
Mark Spector as the main version of Moon Knight.
I think for the most part,
they'll just deal with the Jake Lockley persona
as like the one additional persona during season two.
But the whole idea is that before he can defeat Kaiju
for good, all of his personalities
have to come to an internal agreement
inside his own body.
So that's like the first real battle
he has to face, there a couple of moments like that
in the comics, too,
where like all the personalities sit down and like,
okay, we need to have a little chat here.
they're couple of Major Moon Knight villains
they could still use
as mid bosses, too, like Underneath
Khonshu is being the main boss.
It just depends on what they want
The main theme of season two to be They already changed
the origin of the Arthur Hiro character
from the classic Moon Knight Comics,
making him a version of Shadow Knight,
who in the comics was Moon Knight's Real Brother,
that briefly formed a contract with Kaiju
becoming a more evil version of Moon Knight.
in. That was kind of the backstory of Ethan
Hawke's character, is that he was the previous version
of Moon Knight,
who is a way more hardcore version of the character,
and that's what caused him
to eventually break his contract with Kaiju,
informed the contract with Ahmed,
who admittedly was an even worse God.
But there's black Specter. There's Morpheus.
Not the Sandman version of Morpheus. A different one.
They didn't use werewolf by night,
like I said, because he was meant to debut
during the special presentation.
They can introduce him during the series,
and they can form
a friendship together,
fighting more supernatural monsters.
Then there's Kit Harington's
Black Knight character with his ebony blade.
He was supposed to show up during season one,
but they said that he cut his scenes
because they felt like there weren't
going to be a big enough payoff for the character.
Like people would have expected something
much, much bigger from his character.
he was supposed to be featured in the museum scenes
as another researcher
that they went to for help
uncovering the mystery of Ahmed and the other gods.
so he wasn't going to be doing a ton of Black Night
stuff during the series.
He was mostly going to be there.
Is Dane Whitman
helping there with research based stuff?
supposedly they also removed him from the Blade movie.
The Ebony Blade will be a big part of the Blade movie,
but not the actual Dane Whitman Black Knight character,
which seems kind of weird to me.
But I think part of the blade movie's
meant to take place in the distant past, and that's why
Black Knight isn't in it.
they've been talking about putting together
a version of Marvel's Midnight Suns team.
They can start to do that
towards the end of season two.
I wouldn't expect them to use all of season
two for Midnight Suns related stuff.
Like you have Ghost Rider,
a bunch of other big characters
they have to introduce
before they can actually put that team together.
but they could just set Moon Knight
up to be on that team with all this Avengers
five Avengers secret war stuff
going on talking about some of the other gods too.
They didn't actually use Khonshu's Father
Ra or many members of Khonshu's Pantheon of Gods,
The Aeneid Basically the Egyptian gods,
they can introduce more of them
and use them in a much bigger way
were they actually did during season one is
they just use some of the human avatars
of some of those other gods
who they then killed most of them off,
maybe that the Pantheon would just select new avatars
so the other gods did not die.
Khonshu's Pantheon lives in like another pocket
dimension, kind of the way the TVA exist
or like the Council of Kangs
exist outside of the timeline.
so all the stuff that Loki did at the end of Loki
season two, for instance, messing like repairing
the multiverse did not affect what was happening
with those other places that were outside of time.
one of the other major threads in
this becomes a bigger theme in the comics
is confuse quest for revenge against the other gods.
He's incredibly capricious and he hates
he absolutely hates
all the other gods, mostly
because they banished him to Earth.
there was a brief teaser for his father Wrath.
He's the current leader of their pantheon
since that came into existence.
But like I said, there's the whole idea that bast,
the Panther goddess, is his sister and the goddess
a Black Panther.
So there's just a lot of connections there,
even though I don't think they would ever include
the Black Panther character
in like a Moon Knight series,
they want to keep Black Panther,
whoever is the Black Panther.
Any given moment in the Black Panther movies,
in the Avengers movies,
But they can still include bast the panther goddess.
No problem.
She was featured briefly during Thor, Love and Thunder.
I'm going to go ahead
and assume they didn't want to trash her too much
so she did not go to that
big sex pest business was planning it omnipotent city?
that was part of the whole joke of that.
Like the whole idea that the carpenter God
was basically a version of Jesus, like, did Jesus
go to that giant sex fence to there was a brief Easter
egg for bast during season one,
but like I said, they didn't actually
include the physical character in the season.
there were couple Easter eggs
for the Rama version of Cain,
but like very, very small blink
and you'll miss the Easter eggs.
They're still committed to the Council of Cain
storyline.
Season two would probably have some connection
to Avengers five and Avengers six,
but I think they mostly focus on
whatever internal story that they had in it.
There is like some big connection to Avengers
five that being like a post-credits scene.
I think part of the idea of season two though
is they start to wrap things up
with the three of their personalities.
Mark Spector, Stephen Grant and Jake Lockley
forming an agreement between the three of them
for control of their body, but also defeat Kaiju
and then realize that because we have Avengers
five, Avengers six, like the Earth is threatened
in a much bigger, more cosmic way.
They need the powers of Unite, so they need Kaiju
so they can't kill him.
ba. Let me know in the comments.
What do you want them to do with season two?
There's so much stuff from the comics
that they get so many big connections, like even
just werewolf by night,
even if they don't include Black Knight's character.
I'll do more moonlight videos.
When we learn more about what's happening
with the future of the character,
it'll probably be a little while before they start
making a bunch of really big announcements.
The next real big stuff that's coming up are the
what if season two episodes my episode videos
for that will start in a couple of weeks so make sure
to enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss that.
That'll basically cover
like the entire end of the year.
then we have a whole bunch of Daredevil, Echo
and X-Men 97 episodes early next year.
click here for that Loki Season
2 Beyonder Loki Alternate ending
and deleted scenes and click here for that
brand new trailer for The Scarlet Witch.
Agatha Darkhold Diaries series.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!